ils déterrent les meilleurs d'entre nous
aux meilleurs pilotes commencent à taper
l'intérieur
c'est l'élite
ce sont maintenant des légumes nos
meilleurs légumes était proposé
d'investir meadows as tu t'es combiné de
cuillé 40 au bout ouais 40 tu fais plus
tu payes 45 inversis
après oui et ce avant et 10 adultes en
commun au moins 50 et oui je dis non oui
la vérité désolé jesolo 40
on est les moustaches youth on n'est pas
là pour faire rire
on est là pour faire peur ici c'est le
ministre des cultes c'est le ministre
d'intérieur 1
alors il faut arrêter le massacre est-ce
que vous avez déjà causé la mort de
trois pilotes et la mort c'est une
surprise que l'inconcevable fait aux
consommables françois valéry oui alors
on vient de récolter deux individus oui
alors c'est non boutih canard mais ne
faut pas s'ils sont dus à 402 bloqué au
rez-de-chaussée séries tv ou et vos
tabliers ou plutôt non je quelqu'un a
compris
oui je moi messieurs vous savez lire
surtout des lettres toutes les lettres
même le z os x il l'être aussi
non c'est pas vraiment une lentille un
bruit